rotate
if he's the wise
shrewd Street guy that he is
Tate you can't be naive
and believe Romania is going to protect
you because it's a very corrupt Nation
you don't have more money than other
governments that they can offer to that
country
your 50 million hundred million half a
billion a billion is nothing the U.S
just cut a 1.7 trillion dollar check
that's 1700 billion dollars okay the U.S
just gave 2.6 billion dollars for
January 6th attorneys which they just
dropped the case
couple days ago you think they're gonna
have a hard time buying up Ukrainian a
Romanian government to come after you
and don't know there's no way they're
gonna have a hard time with that there's
better places for him to be if they want
to we saw what they did with uh was it
Julian Assange who was it that was a
Snowden or Assange where they said hey
woman this and woman that and Assange
yeah they have way more methods to their
powers than he believes what Tate needs
to do the next phase when he comes back
if he's going to be wise about this the
next time he comes back is build
stronger alliances he doesn't have a lot
of strong alliances he needs strong
alliances okay you need alliances and
alliances are uh he has a lot of people
that believe in him he has a lot of
people that support him he has a lot of
people that like what he has to say but
you need powerful people to have your
back okay you need you need powerful
alliances I I think you know I think
he's got got to be uh the next time
around if he does come back he needs to
have a better strategy of creating
better alliances and aligns that the
definition is a union or Association
form for Mutual benefit especially
between countries and or organizations
if I give you if I give you powerful
names and I told you what a license they
have I guarantee you could come up with
a bunch of names for different people I
can give you names right now and you can
say yeah that guy's got this backing
from this guy okay Oprah Winfrey what
alliances does she have go ahead Clinton
yeah okay who else our government
Networks tech obahamas she's connected
Studios
you know how many different insurance
policies that is that's a lot of
different insurance policies yeah okay
what's the knock on Trump how many
alliances does he have even if he has
him he burns him anyway so the challenge
is the alliances he wouldn't keep for
too long right you know Colony long
muscular [ __ ] artist yeah that's an
alliance you could have kept yeah Rogan
is a good alliance to keep like these
are good alliances to keep not everybody
is an enemy
so the challenge with the challenge with
the methodology of bullying all the
bullies is sometimes you bully people
that could have been an alliance to you
that you lose yeah and and that's the
only thing that I think you know part of
it obviously the Playbook of the last
six years is to duplicate what Trump did
but
duplicating that without building
alliances long term
it's uh it's it's not it's not the right
strategy I don't think I could be wrong
I don't think that's the right strategy
number one I think what you said was
beyond powerful so like yeah clip that
up clip it boom but
the way that I'm interpreting these
alliances is so there's there's top down
and bottom up okay so one of the more
powerful things that I remember what
Tate said when he talked about Logan
Paul was he's like Logan Paul has
followers
I have fans and there's a big difference
like they're wondering where's Tate
let's go find Tate whereas he compared
uh Logan Paul to sort of a tool of the
Matrix and a monkey and people watch but
they don't they're not fans got you so
all right where am I going with this
we're speaking of alliances so top down
bottom up
bottom up would be the Groundswell of
people that genuinely want to see this
guy win fans okay there's no doubt he
has millions and millions of fans do you
doubt that oh for sure no doubt okay so
that's the bottom-up approach like I'm
not comparing Tate to Gandhi but if you
start on the Grassroots or or if it's a
a Bernie Sanders whether it's a trump
you have a ground swell of people you
have a ground game from the bottom up
that will support you you need that
right
the problem is what Tate doesn't have is
that he doesn't have a top-down approach
there's nobody in the upper echelons of
government Tech Society the global Elite
that is going to come to his defense
nobody and I think that's what you're
referring to when it comes to alliances
you can have the bottom-up approach
amazing but if you're going to go
against the system you better have some
big Bazookas up at the top they're going
to have your back oh but by the way I
think he's got the personality to get
that uh FY some people are dming me
stuff and and from different parts of
the world uh Rob can you do me a favor
and put my link to my Twitter profile if
anybody has anything that they want to
share
and some of the credible stuff if you
can't send it to me I'll I'll bring it
up if you don't want your name to be
mentioned because of whoever you are
I'll respect that no problem but if you
do want uh uh feel free to send this
stuff to my uh Twitter profile just put
the link below the easiest way for
people to go to it so no question but
here's the thing here's the thing that
he has going for himself
he's likable
okay he's very likable he's Charming
he's likable uh uh uh put the exact link
uh exact link to put okay there you go
he's Charming he's likable he's witty
he's smart he's funny
he's also polarizing he's very
polarizing I get that but what I'm
saying is he has the ability to win
Saint status and earn a lot of people's
support he has that oh he has to uh he
has to change uh he has to change his
approach so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]